well listen what we saw during the last
month of 2016 in December of 2016
in January of 2017 was unbelievably
unusual activity that was happening on
on part of the Obama administration so
this doesn't come as a surprise here's
the interesting point I can tell you
that John Durham and attorney general
Barr are going to get to the bottom of
it and in there including and part of
their surveillance really looking at the
intelligence community to make sure that
that justice is brought but I can tell
you I just came back from North Carolina
and here's what I heard John they're
tired of the 12s I want to see people
they weren't Hannity family you I did
North Carolina I did they were you 28
our family he's well I'm nobody got my
nothing this guy was the best I did I
did meet him and many others and what
they're saying is it's time that
somebody goes to jail for for truly
trying to overthrow this president who
was duly elected and and I think
accountability is right around the
corner and Jim Jordan again you know
that you're great at laying out this
case very quickly well it's not this is
real easy what they were trying to do
this is one of the six ways from Sunday
remember the same time they're trying to
change all this with how the
intelligence information is shared among
various agency Chuck Schumer the top
Democrat in the United States Congress
at the time is on one of the other
networks and he says this if you mess
with the intelligence community they
have six ways from Sunday and getting
back at you so this is one of those six
ways coupled with all the other things
we know that you talked about the
dossier the person named Ezra Turk the
plant they put pretending to be somebody
else next to George papadopolis and all
that stuff took place this is exactly
what Chuck Schumer said they were going
to do and it sure looks like they did it
that's why what Mark just said is so
important the Attorney General of the
United States and US Attorney John
Durham are doing an investigation and
they have told us this is broader than
just the FBI they're gonna look at all
of this so they're gonna get to the
bottom of it and this is what has to
happen in our great